ce soir on va désigner qui est le
meilleur animateur entre benjamin
castaldi et matthieu delormeau déjà un
animateur doit être bien habillé voyez
donc que moi je suis un faux animateur
donc vous pouvez le constater après font
leur bonjour et après il y aura diverses
séquences de reste avec nous vaccine gay
ni bien sûr on va les juger
attention matthieu delormeau face à
benjamin castaldi c'est le duel de ce
soir mathieu attention c'est parti on
vous remet un petit jingle pathétique au
livre
[Applaudissements]
mais
c'est mais pour ce prix
exceptionnel dans lequel vous êtes
devoir faire un choix
et oui ce soir c'est un duel d'homme à
homme enfin d'un homme mais avec
quelqu'un d'assez deux hommes
l'attention mais s'est dit quelqu'un
bref les mots ses moyens j'ai accepté de
faire ce prime même si on n'en connaît
l'issue et oui aujourd'hui c'est un peu
le barça contre le marais football club
et cette battle est né du cerveau d'un
génie non mais ba ba ba oui enfin
n'exagérez pas comme si si si si qui va
m'obliger à livrer un combat que
normalement par edu durée de 30 secondes
ça va durer deux heures non non que le
meilleur gagne il en appelle
solennellement à tous mais castaldi a
voté pour moi car si je perds ce soit à
part tv breizh ou hd un jeune aurait
plus beaucoup le choix
et ça m'arrange par rapport à l'argent
et à l'ego qui me reste bref
préparez vous ce soir je vais bouffer de
kader surprise
merci à jamais entendu la fois attention
la tumeur nous vous portez de l'awb a
également fait une entrée non vous ne
faites pas de commenter j'ai changé de
chaîne au bout de deux minutes merci
alors attention le bonjour mathieu
delormeau vous nous direz ce que vous
avez frère de vouziers tout un attention
c'est parti
[Applaudissements]
ouais
c'est vous qui êtes chez vous soyez les
bienvenus ce soir pour une émission
exceptionnelle puisque on va affronter
un match sort enfin un match que dis-je
c'est comme si on mettait mike tyson
face à bernard montiel sur un ring c'est
vous dire c'est gagné d'avancé mais
c'est pas grave vous allez rire ce soir
les amis moi mathieu delormeau
je vous fais confiance à vous public
armés de leurs moeurs je vais affronter
à l'animateur va un ex-animateur que
gilles has been
ah ouais ouais ça va c'est moi qui sais
mon émission que tu auras tu peux dire
je ne renie parole mon grand alors un
homme que seul le plot le pôle emploi
qui l'a vu les gens de la cité tous les
petits car ceux qui sont derrière moi
c'est mon erreur bien dit kader fini le
star bat terminé maintenant nous la
famille la famille de ceux qui mènent
les deux leurs moeurs de la famille des
cités sans trop se forcer
on va tous la mine et mon frère et ça va
être la raf sera très facile tu vas être
tu vas être terminée je te le dis mais
tu es ridicule cher benjamin pour
terminer t comme un pet tu fais beaucoup
de bruit mais personne peut te sentir
[Applaudissements]
c'était ma télé d'hier je suis la télé
du refus montfrin alors les roues ya les
rouilles est né de leurs moeurs votez
pour moi rester devant la télé et vous
allez assister à la fin à la fin du
règne de casta allant view alors assez
vous atteler
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
chez les portes et
sortir le loup
le sac
m
à
[Musique]
merci monsieur le maire c'est les jo
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
oui
les élus
prenez la fin trois reprises à festa
ouais
comment laisse g20
les supporters que je retourne
les parfums
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
l'un d'eux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci attention des raquettes de poids
sur quelques questions
il a marqué trois points pour sar de
natation majeur agacé vous n'avez pas
bien mais évidemment si vous mettez un
point nous gagner le prime du 6 avril
benjamin et vous serez le grand gagnant
de la soirée
attention ce que vous êtes prêts ouais
c'est donc la télé réalité
dans quelle émission nabil at-elle été
découverte l'amour est aveugle c'est
gagné
[Applaudissements]
et